can you maybe comment on um
the full complexity and richness of the
human mind through this process we've
been casually saying cooking
[Music]
fire
and
beta males
leading to cooperation
but how does the the beauty of the human
mind emerge from all of this is there
other further steps we need to
understand or is it as simple as this
language emerging
from
taking over the alpha male and the
cooperation
or am i also over romanticizing how
amazing the human mind is this is just
like one small step in a long journey of
evolution
well if the beauty of the human mind is
the ability
of us all to
be creative
to explore
i
that's one kind of beauty
another kind of beauty is
the
empathy uh
that we can show and we think of that as
beautiful because it is a kind of rare
and
uh and special
ability compared to
uh the sort of ordinary selfishness um
that
can commonly predominate
um i suppose we have to think of you
know different sources for those those
two types
i suppose you know a general answer is
that
there has been selection in favor of
bigger brains which probably in general
has been associated with increasing
cognitive ability
and as that has happened
i
the complexity of life has increased
because
people have more and more
complex
highly differentiated strategies in
response to each other's more complex
highly differentiated
and we get to a point where there is
deception and self-deception
uh there is some
uh
a manipulation of ideas through
stories that we invent and stories that
we pass on um
you know i guess all i'm
wanting to say is that
there is a world of
the mind
that
evolves in response
to these platforms that are put there
you know the platform of
increasing brain size and therefore
cognitive ability made possible by
uh increased energy supply
the platform of
uh cooperation and
tolerance in a world in which there
remains a lot of conflict
and therefore a need to respond to the
conflict and manipulate your allies
appropriately
you know i don't see beauty as coming uh
either kind of beauty is coming so
totally independently of these things
um you know i don't think there's a
selection
for
staring into the sunset and creating
poetry
yes you know but um i guess sexual
selection
you know males
wanting to impress females in different
ways will lead to
um them wanting to
write poetry
well yes you know show off yeah in all
the different ways so all of these are
natural consequences of uh just coming
up with strategies of how to cooperate
and uh how to achieve certain ends so
that's just like a natural
yeah i mean we haven't spoken about
sexual selection but but that is a
really important part of it you know
they
trying to out compete each other in
um
normally without any physical conflict
uh just in order to be able to be chosen
by mates of the opposite sex and that
that is certainly a major source of
creativity
you